[Music]
good morning - PS thank you for sharing
this moment with us
gracias para compartir este momento con
nosotros we would like to welcome you to
let's get em estado nagaram be a minute
on the 23rd annual dr. Martin Luther
King celebration
we would also like a moment to take a
moment to thank tenemos tomar esta
oportunidad Paradise gracias ah
president Charles vest and his wife
Rebecca vest for hosting this event
thank you very much
[Applause]
we would also like to welcome Tom yankin
I must I live when I ran bian many da ah
miss Elaine Jones
[Applause]
it is a pleasure to have you with us
here this morning and some placenta
compartir coasters esta mañana we would
like to thank all of the members kmo
Stanislas gracias a todos los miembros
de of the Martin Luther King jr.
celebration committee to whom we owe
this wonderful morning I can't let MMS
estimate a video so mañana when we call
your names please stand up cuando yo
mama tsunami report from our phone casa
de PA professor Phil Klay
[Applause]
Maureen Costello
professor Jerome I Freedman
Reverend Jane Gould Kenneth L Hale
professor Wesley Harris
being Arnold Henderson Junior
[Applause]
Morrison
mr. Richard O'Brien Dean Martin Daniels
Tyler
and baby shower
mr. Robertson sir mr. Ronald Kay Sudoku
can you see navidad add-in cochairs
professor Michael s felt and Dean leo
awesome
in addition we would like to express our
appreciation to the student volunteers
na dstean kenny most analyst classes
Alice estudiantes voluntarios who were
here very early to help with the
preparations thank you very much
[Applause]
and those students are Jonathan white
Amir Ali Needham Angela neo Michell
Hicks Maya Kent well Mary Tara Mendez
Luciano Salazar Karina Serna and am
poncho thank you very much for
contributing to the success of this
event gracias a todos for come 3-wood
Alexey tourist event oh thank you both
Kimberly and Kira is this a distinct
pleasure to be a master of ceremonies at
the 23rd annual dr. Martin Luther King
jr. award breakfast please know a slight
change in your program after dr. vest
recognized the recipients of the MLK
Leadership Awards he introduced Miss
Catherine born the vice mayor of
Cambridge who represent two citations
that I make from the community now let
us begin our program with the invocation
by chaplain reverend Constance f'p RV
will begin breakfast right after that
Reverend par V let us pray
gracious and loving God we give you
things for our brother the Reverend dr.
Martin Luther King for his life for his
death for his resurrection in our midst
for his dream for the commitment that he
has developed in the hearts and minds of
all those who are gathered here and
millions of people around the world for
the life which he has given us to live
on for this place for the
african-american students who are
studying here the professor's the
administrators for the many students
from black culture who will come here
and study and who have and will
contribute to the life of Science and
Technology and human values across the
world we give you things for the
strength the vision the courage of
Martin Luther King and the incredible
inheritance that he gives us and so this
morning may we through the gifts of your
creation be strengthened in our
friendship with one another and in our
resolve to live out that dream in the
name of the Almighty God the God of love
and mercy I'm in ladies and gentlemen
hope I hope you've joined you enjoy your
breakfast as much as I have but you
can't fall asleep on us now the best
part of the program is yet to come
I had the pleasure of introducing two of
our very own students 800 to TIG Bay
class of 1999 in the department of
mechanical engineering and Cedric Logan
a graduate student in the Department of
Electrical Engineering and computer
science they'll both guide us in a
reflection on the life of dr. King
aho
[Applause]
good morning I am a total tech BAE a
sophomore in mechanical engineering I
have a question for you are you guilty
what about you are we you're guilty
today it is very easy for us to carry on
with our day-to-day activities and
ignore all those around us we find it
convenient to exist in our personal
boxes and tend to our personal agendas
think about it how often do you take
time out to give someone a hand how
often do you give thoughtful
consideration to someone who may not be
as well off as you are how often do we
sacrifice ourselves in the name of love
you see part of life's difficulties
arise when we choose to step out of our
personal confines and into someone
else's doing so is a challenge because
it requires a special strength in order
to deal with someone who may not share
the same ideals that you do this
requires the strength to love to love is
the most powerful thing that any human
being can do I said - love is the most
powerful thing that any human being can
do because loving destroys hate
eliminates ignorant builds positivity a
positivity that is much needed in such a
negative world as our own positivity
that will aid us in resolving the
world's present-day issues because you
see the problem with today's problems is
that they come from so many different
sources some more clandestine
others can you pinpoint the ink the
exact cause of the increase in
black-on-black violence to a single
culprit what about the high percentages
of AIDS in the black community
then there's materialism and greed and
low personal expectations low self-worth
and disunity and on and on and on though
the causes of these are hidden the
effects are quite apparent
there is no single formula to save the
world
but there is a single power that is the
power of love
Universal self-sacrificing
all enduring l.o.v.e this was the power
the strength the dr. King wielded with
the skill and precision and passion of a
true warrior he refused to let up in his
struggle
he stood boldly against angry mobs hot
climates corrupt law officials and even
some of his own people who did not have
the faith that he did in the struggle in
order to love we must develop the
qualities that permitted dr. King to
overcome such things these qualities are
tough minds and tender hearts with tough
minds and tender hearts we can work to
dispel the MIT apathy that exists in
much of our student body strategic
agendas can be comprised to make
positive advancements within the MIT
community then human alliances can be
can be formed to better the MIT
Cambridge and Boston community as
members of one of the world's most
prestigious scientific institutions we
have a responsibility to utilize our
abilities our science must be used to
scrutinize and identify the problems of
our people then our faith must be used
to interpret and rectify them
all this done in the name of love dr.
King I found the strength to love at a
time when it seemed that doing so was
against the law today February 6th 1997
if love was against the law would you be
guilty what about you would be all be
guilty thank you
Wow
that was 800 - tick Bay class of 1999
Cedric Logan please first I would like
to express my thanks to the Martin
Luther King jr. celebration committee
for allowing me to speak here today
today when I reflect upon the impact of
the life of dr. King and countless
others like him
I am personally filled with a deep sense
of gratitude today I am grateful that I
can be a farm boy from Lowndes County
Alabama and that I can be an engineer
today I am grateful that I can walk into
a voting booth in my hometown of
Haynesville Alabama where in 1965 a
young white minister named Jonathan
Daniels was gunned down in broad
daylight for helping with black voter
registration today I am grateful that I
could walk across the Edmund Pettus
Bridge to Selma Alabama and expect to be
served in any restaurant and to be
allowed to drink from any water fountain
today I'm grateful to dr. King and those
of his generation for bringing America
from the land of slavery Jim Crow and
legalized oppression to the very door
the promised land and even personally
today I'm grateful that I could walk
through the door of my alma mater the
University of Alabama with a textbook
and a calculator rather than just a
broom in a shovel in the spirit of the
11th chapter of the book of Hebrews dr.
King and those of his generation ought
to be commended for their faith even
though they did not receive the things
promised but only saw them and welcomed
them from a distance in the spirit of
the 12th chapter of the book of Hebrews
the challenge for our present generation
is to throw off everything that hinders
bitterness hatred complacency and apathy
and to run with perseverance the race
marked out for us then and only then in
the eyes of the Creator with a life and
legacy of
dr. King and those of his generation be
made perfect
Sedgwick Logan
like to personally thank both 8o and
cedric hope everyone has not only
listened but will take heed to the words
they they spoke this morning now I'd
like to introduce our next speaker dr.
John H Cartwright dr. Cartwright is
currently the dr. Martin Luther King jr.
professor of social ethics at Boston
University and the president of the
console societies for the study of
religion beyond the classroom dr.
Cartwright has served as training
associate and administrator of Boston
University's summer laboratory in the
approvement of human relations and was
from 1968 to 1970 the founding director
of the university's King Center since
1977 dr. Cartwright has served as a dr.
Martin Luther King jr. professor of
social ethics and since 1991 has served
as the executive secretary of the
Society of Christian ethics that's quite
a resume please join me in welcoming dr.
Cartwright
[Applause]
to the committee and to Dean's Tyler and
Osgood and honored guests it is my
privilege to be on this side of the
river for a change
surprisingly things look about the same
over here as they do over there it's
hard to follow these two students
tremendous I wish I could get you into
my class speaking of that I think if I
weren't here I would I would be teaching
about this time so I know that my
students would like to thank you or and
that marvelous introduction that you
gave reminded me of a favorite story of
Martin King that whenever he would be
given the kinds of introductions you can
imagine had this story of Billy Graham I
guess is America's resident preacher and
it seems that Billy Graham is conducting
one of his crusade discovered in his
pocket and all all of the men here will
will have had this experience a letter
that you should have mailed sometime
before and while he had a break he
thought he would run down to the post
office so he he went out and said well
where is it and he saw this kid and he
said a young man would you help me I
need to find the post office said
there's no problem sister just go two
blocks this way and then you turn right
in and it's right there he said thank
you sir
do you know who I am and the young man
said no he said well I'm I'm the
Reverend Billy Graham and I'm holding
fourth over there at the stadium tonight
and I tell you what if you come over
I'll show you the way to heaven and
little boy said Oh gone you don't even
know the way to post office and probably
its most appropriate for me because I
didn't even otherway to the parking lot
this morning
I would like to say a few words about
someone that I feel very deeply about we
were in school together for a bit and I
have walked as well as I can in in his
footsteps over the years and exceedingly
privileged to to carry a title
associated with him I want to say just a
word about a king stature as a scholar
and his writings the somewhat
controversial area but I think it's
something that I could share
meaningfully with you you remember and
please bear with me if I say some things
that you already know just doze off for
a couple seconds but King was was
graduated from Morehouse College in
Atlanta in 1948 with a Bachelor of Arts
degree in sociology he subsequently went
to Crozer Theological Seminary in
Chester Pennsylvania for his Bachelor
Divinity degree he in fact delivered the
valedictorian address that the
commencement he went there in 1948 and
finished 1951 and immediately enrolled
in September 51 at Boston University in
the Graduate School many people say the
School of Theology but he was a student
in the graduate school as a PhD
candidate in systematic theology in 1964
after King had B had become
King he officially donated his papers to
Boston University but due to his tragic
death the papers from approximately 1963
to the end of his life were not
forwarded to Boston University but
became part of the King Center archives
in Atlanta and fortunately for scholars
and others the Martin Luther King jr.
papers project was initiated in 1984 by
mrs. King and the King Center the goal
of the project is to assemble over the
next 15 years
as I said in 1984 a 12 volume scholarly
edition of the speeches sermons
correspondence and other writings of
Martin Luther King jr. to date the first
two volumes in that series have been
published under the general editorship
of Clayborne Carson at the Stanford
University this will make it possible
sometime in the future when all twelve
volumes are done for scholars to at
every library in the world perhaps to
have access to the total corpus of the
writings of Martin King rather than the
situation today of having to shovel
between Boston University and the King
Center king's pilgrimage into
non-violence which is in a sense his
most characteristic thing I think was a
journey into the formation of a
comprehensive and coherent social
philosophy that was grounded
fundamentally in a metaphysics that
included a personal God a Christian
systematic theological perspective and
an ethic of the dignity and worth of the
human personality
and concerning his theology his major
professor at Boston University el carril
de Wolfe wrote that at nearly all points
his system with positive theological
belief was identical with his major
professors and he said occasionally I
find his language following closely the
special terms of my own lectures and
writings nevertheless
the main original theological
contribution of his tragically shortened
life and career was his remarkably
consistent translating of his theology
into action in this process he related
his theological beliefs in an authentic
and original way to various social
theories and movements of his time and
in doing so King has made what many of
us feel to be a singular contribution to
modern religious thought using the words
of Jesus of Nazareth and the example of
Gandhi in India King was the first and
remains the foremost to really
articulate the concept of non-violence
and nonviolent resistance for the
American context having said all of that
it would appear that Martin King would
be vilified by those who would disagree
with them and extolled by those who
understood and loved him however about
the about the beginning of the 80s began
to be a rumbling in the air and this
rumbling originally began in and about
the status of his dissertation that
rumbling
led many to begin to question whether or
not dr. King's scholarship was as
authentic as it should have been in
early in 1988 a Stanford graduate
student and staff member on the King
papers project noticed instances of
king's failure to cite sources as the
student was scrutinizing collateral
texts to find the sources and allusions
in King's dissertation and following
this discovery the King project made an
intensive intensive effort between 1988
and 1990 to find a pattern of citation
and borrowing in Kings more than 40
graduate papers the project staff found
that many of the papers King wrote as a
graduate student at Crozer Theological
Seminary between 1948 and 51 and at
Boston University between 1951 and 54
including the dissertation that he
defended in 1955 contained frequent
instances where he used the words of
other writers without giving them credit
and after the scope of this problem had
become clear it behooves Boston
University to address this specifically
with regard to the dissertation since we
had some people suggesting that we
should in fact revoke his PhD and
perhaps substitute that with the
honorary degree or some section thought
that was never discussed the president
appointed a blue-gray blue-ribbon
committee of four with one outside
professor I was included on that
committee
to come to the bottom of this and to
issue a statement on behalf of the
university we came to the conclusion
that the dissertation is in fact flawed
and that a permanent letter be attached
to the dissertation indicating that it
is flawed and that for chapter and verse
one should consult the King papers
project we went on to say however that
that should not since King was not alive
to speak for himself that that fact of
his dissertation should not take away
one iota from his statue as a leader and
as a person and as one who gave the last
full measure of devotion for all of us
know the real question following that of
course is what is the historical and
biographical significance of the papers
that Martin King wrote including his
dissertation the project discovered so
many deficiencies in his papers that
only a few students of King had bought
them deserving of the type of careful
study that should have been given to
them his appropriation of the words and
deeds of others should certainly not be
understood merely as violations of
academic rules they also indicate his
singular ability to intertwine his words
and ideas with those of others to
express his beliefs persuasively and to
construct a persona with a broad
transracial appeal so though in large
measure derivative Kings student papers
document an important stage in the
development of his thought and
his leadership qualities and as he mind
theological texts for Nuggets of potency
that would serve his academic ends king
resolved long-standing religious doubts
that he had and refined a mother a
method of eclectic composition that
would enrich his sermons his speeches
and his published writings now his his
borrowings from euro-american and
african-american religious thought
supplied him with a framework for
understanding perhaps the flaws in his
own character he may simply have
concluded that his academic credentials
and theological readings had served
positive purposes so in one of his last
sermons King may have spoken of his own
life when he addressed the Ebony's a
congregation on a passage from the book
of Mark recounting the quest of James
and John to sit beside Jesus King saw
the two men's desire for recognition is
understandable before we condemned them
too quickly he said let us look calmly
and honestly at ourselves and we will
discover that we too have those basic
desires for recognition we all want to
be important to surpass others to
achieve distinction to lead the parade
he explained somehow this warm glow we
feel when we appraised or when our name
is in print is something of the
vitamin-a to our ego he warned however
that the drum major instinct was
dangerous if not restrained it causes
you to lie about whom you know sometimes
to try to identify with the so called
big name people feelings of snobbishness
could even invade the church so he said
in that sermon the church is a one place
where a pea
HD or to forget that he is a PhD and
King's interpretation of the biblical
story was that Jesus did not oppose the
drum major instinct but in instead
believed that it should be put to the
purposes if you want to be great
wonderful but recognize that he who is
greatest among you shall be your servant
you don't have to have a college degree
to serve you don't have to know about
Plato and Aristotle to serve and he
ended the sermon by referring to his own
desire for recognition separating those
aspects of his identity that were
superficial from the ones he deemed were
essential suggesting the text for his
eulogy King advised tell them not to
mention that I have a Nobel Peace Prize
that isn't important tell them not to
mention where I went to school I'd like
somebody to mention that day that Martin
Luther King jr. tried to give his life
serving others and so what is what is it
that we can in a sense conclude from
this I wish I had more time to spell out
more I've just been able to be a bit
sketchy but as one who has studied King
very closely and for many years it is my
considered opinion that as so many have
said before me that King really did not
originate most of his ideas in fact mrs.
King when I invited her to Boston
University some years ago that's how she
began her address she said her husband
was not an original thinker which I said
we've had taken aback by but in any case
essentially I think the conclusion is
that he was not so
much a creative theologian but a
clergyman not an originator of ideas but
a messenger of them he could be styled
more in my terms as an ideological
leader rather than a charismatic one the
charismatic leaders wisdom is considered
to be the truth simply because he or she
utters it the ideological leader on the
other hand is one whose leadership comes
from an ability to interpret an existing
belief system in a most compelling
manner indeed as David Halberstam said
of King he could make the congregation
of a country church say Amen to a
quotation from Plato so I believe that
in as we look to the future of King
scholars will continue to debate and as
we look to the point where the King
papers project will come to an end and
we will have all of the chapter and
verse we can then make a better
assessment of a king as a scholar but in
the meantime would you pardon me if I
just say that a lot of that is strictly
academic and that what we are really
talking about today is not so much
dissertations and papers and citations
although as an academic I must take
those things terribly seriously but more
today when I think of King I think about
a committed life I think about all of
the work that's left to be done that he
was so sure that one day it would be
done and I know that somewhere Martin
King is saying about this occasion and
all such occasions keep up the spirit
thank you
dr. John kaat right now I have the
distinct honor of introducing the 15th
president of MIT dr. Charles M vest
dr. vest is also the chairman of the
board of directors of gem the National
Consortium for graduate degrees for
minorities in engineering and science
incorporated this is about one of the
many significant roles that dr. vest has
played on a national level president
vest will present the recipients of the
1996-1997 dr. Martin Luther King
Leadership Award for alumni faculty
students or student groups and might I
add we both have an appointment together
in June a graduation dr. vest
[Applause]
well I do have the unmailed letter in my
pocket fortunately my wife Becky knows
where the post office is so when I get
lost as usual she'll she'll save me
thank you very much Greg and I do look
forward to that appointment with you and
June very much and thank all of you for
being here this morning it now is my
great pleasure and privilege to present
this year's Martin Luther King
Leadership Awards this past Monday the
Boston Globe ran a story noting how
relatively short is the list of black
Americans and other minority figures who
receive widespread attention in history
and social science classes in America
the article then listed a long roster of
distinguished Americans who remain
almost unknown to our youth several were
cited for their groundbreaking work in
Industrial Technology biochemistry and
architecture all fields of great
interest here at MIT yet even here I
suspect there are few if any students
faculty staff or presidents who can tell
you much about janmaat seliger norbert
real ill dr. charles drew or benjamin
banneker this lack of awareness of the
role the value and the importance of
diversity in our culture is a legacy of
our past but it is no meat by no means a
mere historical artifact even in today's
mass culture too few of our heroes are
drawn from sources other than the ranks
of athletes and entertainers well I do
not wish for a moment to underrate the
achievements of these figures I do wish
we could make more room in our mass
culture for the celebration of Americans
like WC Patton who died on January 16th
at the age of 84 WC Patton was a school
teacher and the principal
who set out to lead a modest voter
registration effort in post-war Alabama
and ultimately rose to become the
n-double-a-cp s national director of
voter education opposed he held for 22
years if American students of all races
knew just a fraction about people like
WC hatton is that they know about rock
stars and athletes our nation would be a
much better place and it is for this
very reason that the Martin Luther King
jr. Leadership Awards are so important
to all of us at MIT
these awards provide us with a welcome
opportunity to celebrate the
contributions of diversity to the larger
world of higher learning at the same
time they allow us to celebrate
individuals who exemplify the ideals of
dr. King
and inspire us all to incorporate those
ideals into our own lives our first
award this year goes to a group since
its inception in 1994 the MIT committee
on campus race relations has greatly
enhanced our University's dialogues on
race and on culture through its
publication sponsored events and grants
programs this committee has worked to
achieve a greater sense of tolerance and
appreciation for diversity on our campus
above all however the committee has
promoted a greater sense of shared
community no organization could more
thoroughly embody the legacy of dr.
Martin Luther King jr. accepting the
award on behalf of the committee or its
co-chairs professor James Chun and
Professor Ellen Harris would you please
come up and while they're coming with
the other members of the committee
please stand to be recognized
[Applause]
thank you for this award Thank You
president vest and thank you to the
martin luther king committee for
honoring the work that we have tried to
do over the past three years in terms of
the life of Martin Luther King and
speaking on behalf of the committee I
think that we can say that Martin Luther
King taught us that a dream is a vision
and not just wishful thinking that
nonviolent action is an action and not
passivity and that when we cherish our
little achievements that we don't settle
for our little achievements and that we
can't change our society by accepting
just a little bit here and a little bit
there what we need to think about
transformation and in light of the dream
and the action and the transformation
that still needs to come the Committee
on campus race relations accepts this
award as an incentive to do much more
thank you
[Applause]
our next award goes to Mayra Rodriguez a
member of the MIT staff who has devoted
herself to assisting those in need in a
quarter century of service to the
Institute social services and medical
department she has proven that one of
the best ways to enhance an entire
community is to help one person at a
time many lives have been touched by her
compassion by her wisdom we cannot think
of a more fitting recipient of an award
that bears the name of dr. Martin Luther
King jr.
thank you
thank you so much I know I'm among
friends I just have so much I have so
many deep and well-meant
feelings over the years of being here
and looking at how Martin looking Luther
King's ideals have affected my life and
my work here at MIT I just want to
commend the Martin Luther King committee
for because I know over the years all
the hard work it takes to put an event
like this together and they have worked
tirelessly I just think you know that
him being here for 25 years I was told I
could speak for a minute a minute and a
half that can become difficult for
someone who for the most advanced
professional life has listened and
listened and listened so I will try to
stay within that time frame I want to
say that and being here at MIT all these
years I know that this is the 23rd event
that the Martin Luther King committee
has presented but it is not the 23rd
year that Martin Luther King Day has
been a holiday at MIT I recall somewhere
in the mid 70s that I and John Turner
who was assistant dean to the Graduate
School in his life clove on the three of
us approached who then was Chancellor
gray and had a conversation with him
about Martin Luther King Day being an
institute holiday this was before it was
this national holiday before it was a
state holiday and we went the rounds and
the rounds and there are times when I
think we were like fools rush in where
angels fear to dread tread or maybe
Shadrach Meshach and Abednego not that
the dr. Grey's office was the fiery
furnace
but we do know that we did not go in
there alone dr. gray talked and we
talked to we negotiated and he said well
this would have to be taken to the
Academic Council and it was presented to
the Academic Council and it seems that
there was very little discussion as to
whether it should be and it was and this
was in 1978 so MIT was in a leadership
role because it was not a national
holiday nationally until 1986 it was a
holiday in Massachusetts in 1985 and we
impressed on dr. gray that MIT could
take a leadership role in this respect
and and I said well we wouldn't even be
the first because bu I had already made
it a holiday and he said well he was an
alumnus of video so that's okay MIT
still has a leadership role to play in
that part my work here at MIT I feel has
reflected some of the ideals that I so
admire and dr. King first his walk as a
Christian his courage and his commitment
it certainly DuckTales with the values
that my profession as a social worker
holds and the mission of my profession
for social and economic justice there is
another of the many many many many
experiences that I could share with you
about my experience here at MIT all that
I've learned from the students the kinds
of things that the students who took
part in this event today have done over
the years and just the remarkable towers
that our african-american students have
that sometimes feel forded but with the
support and the role that one can paint
play in their lives to see them just
bloom and achieve and how often we as
african-american adults in the community
have to serve as filters to filter out
some of the negative messages so they do
not incorporate that into who they are
one of the other things that I just
cherish about having been here at
my tias being part of the building on
differences committee and planning group
and being a facilitator in that event
given the increasing polarization in our
society I believe that this effort needs
to be continued because if people can
talk together get to know each other as
individuals look at their strengths and
weaknesses accept their strengths and
weaknesses so they don't have to project
those onto other people that that will
be a beginning and bringing people
together I think I did a stop I thought
I was speechless I thought I was
speechless but I wasn't again I just
want to thank president best thank the
MIT community the Martin Luther King
committee and all my colleagues because
to be an awardee and to have all of the
positive thing feedback from my
colleagues who have known me for 25
years and have what this distance with
me is a singular honor thank you
well Meyer you may have thought you were
just listening all those years but I
think your actions have been speaking
volumes continuously and that's why you
felt all that warmth today thank you
our third award goes to Professor s
James Gates distinguished scholar who
earned multiple undergraduate and
graduate degrees here at MIT culminating
in 1977 with the PhD in physics since
1984 he has been a member of the physics
faculty at the University of Maryland he
has also served as chairman of the
Howard University Physics Department and
was the first director of a NASA
supported center for the study of
terrestrial and extraterrestrial
atmospheres
although the demands of this
professional career could easily be
all-consuming Jim has always remained
committed to a larger social agenda a
spirited and articulate defender of
affirmative action he exemplifies the
potential in our society that our
society can unlock by providing
opportunity to all of its citizens by
achieving greatly and by championing the
virtues of diversity in science and in
the larger scientific community Jim
sustains both the vision and the
excellence embodied by dr. Martin Luther
King we are honored by his presence here
today Jim
[Applause]
well on these sorts of occasions most of
us are a lot of us at least really are
speechless of course I'd like to begin
by thanking Chuck the selection
committee for the Martin Luther King
celebration for thanks go to Professor
Jerome Friedman and some of my longtime
colleagues here for example professor
Lionel trilling professor Michael Feld
and other members of the physics
department that had such a role to play
in my career as Chuck said in his
introduction I'm a product of this
institution having been an undergraduate
graduate student and holding my first
faculty appointment here and while it is
true that I spend most of my time
dreaming about problems that Albert
Einstein left us I also contemplate
problems with this nation it's a great
nation Americans have always been
peoples of a dream and yet throughout
its history we find that it has been
fractally tessellated with problems of
an ancient string well we don't gain
anything by running from facts and in my
discipline as a scientist mathematics
and logic are the two things that I can
hang my hat on and making progress so we
have to face facts about this nation we
do not serve her well when we do less
than bear our full efforts to the
principles upon which this nation was
built it's a struggle that we each meet
every day we must commit ourselves to
excellence because in the end that's
what really makes this country a great
place this excellence must be across the
board and yet many will tell you that a
commitment to excellence is that odds
with a commitment to equity these things
are not at odds in my opinion and in
fact throughout my career I have
endeavored to both prove that to be the
case in my own personal actions
to pursue policies and actions that
allow others to prove this it is urgent
that we continue along these lines of
progress the new millennium is coming
and you certainly hear lots of debate of
that in the public conversation sometime
in the next 50 or so years European
Americans will be in the minority in
this Paulo population for the first time
we had all better think about the
consequences of what that means for this
nation for it would be perhaps the
greatest of tragedies if this nation
which I certainly regard as the sweetest
of dreams that has been dreamt by our
species were to fall into a situation of
a Bosnia that's not what I want for my
nation that's not what I want for my
children and that's certainly not what I
want for any institution and that
certainly includes this one here thank
you
[Applause]
thank you Jim for those most important
words we've used the term community
several times today and we are part of a
civic community as well as an academic
one and we are honored today by the
presence of several elected officials
from the city of Cambridge they would
like to recognize their presence and ask
them to stand here this morning we have
our vice mayor
Kathleen borne you'll hear a bit more
about her in a moment city county city
councillors ken Reeves Kathryn Tran to
fellow
and Frances do hey also with us today is
former mayor Walter Sullivan and one of
our state representatives Paul DeMarcus
Paul and now I would like to turn the
podium over to Vice Mayor Kathleen
Bourne who will present two resolutions
on behalf of the city before I let go of
the microphone however I should tell you
that Kathy Bourne is not only one of the
leaders of our city she holds a master's
degree from MIT School of Architecture
which makes us doubly glad to have here
have her here this morning
vice mayor born
[Applause]
Thank You president theft it's an honor
indeed to be here on be and to bring
greetings on behalf of the city of
Cambridge mayor Russell sends her
regrets she had another engagement but
she offers her thanks to MIT and joins
me in congratulations as do all of my
colleagues to the award recipients that
have been honored here today and also
we'd like to extend a very warm welcome
from the city of Cambridge to the MIT
visiting professors who will be honored
as well I'd like to say a few words
about dr. King briefly I believe that
every one of us carries with us certain
mental images of famous people I like to
think of John Kennedy in the with his
hair blowing in the wind taking the oath
of office on the steps of Congress I
think of Bobby Kennedy you know in a
video clip sort of taking his coat off
when he was campaigning when someone
mentions Abraham Lincoln to me I don't
know why but my mind is always drawn not
to the photographs or to the paintings
but to the image of him in the Lincoln
Memorial
when people talk about George Washington
I always think of Washington Alston's
famous painting of him standing at the
prow of a boat crossing the river on his
way to a battle in Philadelphia and I
imagine that many of you think of dr.
King standing behind a podium or perhaps
in a pulpit but I have a somewhat
different image of him and it's an image
that I really like to think about at
this time of year and I'd like to just
share with you a little story about how
that how that image I think came to
roost in my brain when dr. King was
assassinated I was living overseas and I
had been there for about two years at
that point I was living in Cambridge
England with my husband who was an
engineering student there at the time
and we were very isolated from what was
going on in America we didn't have a
television we didn't have a telephone
our contact with the outside world was
the London Times that was delivered to
our doorstep every day and
which carried very little in the way of
American news we had a little transistor
radio that played out very scratchy
programs we had four choices then you
had the BBC program one program to
program three and program four and the
BBC at that time carried very little
very very little I would say authentic
news about the turmoil that was going on
in America at that time the turmoil over
race relations and the turmoil over the
Vietnam War we also on occasion were
able to borrow a shortwave radio and
pull in some of the American I guess
what's it called Radio Free America
broadcasts and in fact we were located
quite close to the Lakenheath airbase
and I believe that they transmitted some
of these broadcasts from there but they
were censored broadcasts and they didn't
include much about the anti everything
that was going on in America and so I
didn't have an awful lot of exposure to
dr. King's speeches and to the movement
that he was leading from my perch over
there in Cambridge England and I
remember on the day that dr. King was
assassinated I learned about it I was
pushing my baby in a stroller
down Main Street in Cambridge England
and someone said dr. King's been
assassinated dr. King's been
assassinated and someone else said who
was dr. King and I remember sort of
filling in a group of grocers on who dr.
King was and I went home in the
afternoon and turned on the BBC and
there at last they were playing a whole
series of dr. King's speeches and I
remember sitting there and in there in
the dark
it was just dusk listening to those
speeches for probably an hour an hour
and a half on the radio there was very
little commentary and I should mention
that the other way that we got our news
is that one of my husband's colleagues
had a subscription to Time magazine and
I think he got it a week late which is
what you if you were an overseas
subscriber you got and about every month
he would pile together his old time
magazines and leave them on our doorstep
so that we would read time about a month
sometimes two months late and that
evening
pile of time magazines appeared on our
doorstep and in one of the magazines
which was probably published about four
weeks before dr. King's death there was
an article about him and there was a
picture in it there wasn't of him
standing behind a pulpit and it wasn't
of him standing behind a microphone it
was a picture of him sitting on a
folding chair in a room preparing for a
speech it was a well it was it was a not
a fancy room it was a room probably the
back room at a church someplace in the
south and there were other people in the
room but they weren't near him and his
head was bent and I think the caption
underneath it I don't remember very
clearly I think it might have said dr.
King prepares her speech but that's what
I believe that he was doing and in his
face there was a look of just incredible
contemplation and incredible
thoughtfulness and for one reason or
another I've carried that image of him
to this holiday every year I think that
the thing that I admired the most about
him was his inner strength and his
ability I think this goes back to what
dr. Cartwright had said earlier his
ability to really synthesize the ideas
of Christianity and of faith and hope
and justice and fairness and bring them
to the people in a way that was
accessible to everyone who listened I
was struck before during my Rodriguez's
comments till they took me back a little
bit to the days in the late 70s in the
early 80s when the King Holiday had just
been proposed and I remember some of the
people who objected to that holiday said
well January isn't a good time for a
holiday
never mind that this is actually when
dr. King's birthday was we just we've
just had a period of great celebration
and everybody has taken holidays at the
New Year's and over the Christmas season
and this is an appropriate time to have
another holiday and I've really come
during the years when this holiday has
been become a national holiday and when
we've all celebrated it the way that we
do now with breakfasts and and really
with a whole month of contemplation I've
really come to feel the January is a
perfect time for this holiday and I was
struck driving down here along Hampshire
Street at the way that the world looks
in January
the leaves are off of the trees the
light is sort of a gray light rather
than a sunny light it's really one of my
favorite months and I people are always
astounded when I say that I love January
but I love January because I think it's
a time for us all to look inward and to
gather strength from what we can find in
our own hearts and our own minds and I
associate that with my image of dr. King
sitting there quietly on his folding
chair paying no attention to the people
who were around him I think he was
gathering strength for the moment when
he would stand up behind the microphone
or in the pulpit and bring his message
of hope and justice and an action to all
of us so I welcome you all here on
behalf of the city I would like to
present this resolution to dr. vest
which is a resolution
thanking MIT for putting on this
breakfast and also congratulating all
the people were honoring here today and
I would like to call my colleague former
mayor ken Reeves to the podium he has a
resolution that he would like to present
welcoming our keynote speaker thank you
all
I'm gonna be characteristically brief I
wanted to say hi to Chuck and Becky and
it's always nice to be at MIT and
congratulations to our honorees our very
own Myra Rodriguez who believe it or not
is the real Cantor bridge room
and professor gates and to the Committee
on race relations but really why I'm
here while you're having to civic
proclamations is that I beat them to the
punch I heard that you were having
Elaine Jones and I said well I am going
to be sure we give her a special welcome
I don't know if you know who our speaker
is this morning but she is a true drum
majorette for Justice she is a national
treasure she has traveled the highways
and byways of this country to assure
that there can be equal justice for all
and she's really a profound example to
me of someone who truly leads a
meaningful life who really does
something that's important and soon
you're gonna know she's a great favorite
of mine I could listen to her all day
she has a certain inimitable way that
you're gonna hear all about many of us
hear about heroes she for me is a true
Shiro and she is special just very
special now she has come here before for
many of the NAACP Legal Defense Fund
lunches and I happen to spend two
minutes with her and my buddy Nancy
gifts from the Bureau of Justice
Assistance at the Congressional Black
Caucus which I started treasurer those
kinds of moments when somebody who
really inspires you is around so if you
really want to know who is really doing
this Martin Luther King kind of work
today you have got it and you know I
never go to breakfast ever ever go
directly but
I just don't do it it's too early it's
just too early to get people up and I
think the last time I was here for
breakfast you had another Shiro which
was Coretta Scott King so Elaine Jones I
never come to breakfast but I heard they
was having you so I wanted us all to
give you a real Cambridge welcome for
somebody who so marvelously with such
sagacity goes and sort of represents
truth and justice for all and I'm glad
to know you are representing us wherever
you go
welcome to Cambridge this special little
place thank you
Thank You Ken and Thank You Cathy now
you know when you have a job like mine
you're always standing up receiving the
credit for things that other people do
and there have been a lot of people that
work hard to make events like this a
success we've got a great committee a
great group of students but everybody in
this room knows it takes a couple of
sparkplugs to really make something like
this go and just get better year after
year so I'd like once again as I hold
this award in my hand to recognize Leo
Osgood and Michael felt our co-chairs
[Applause]
thank you to both both is cathlin born
in mr. Kenneth Reeves is now my pleasure
to introduce dr. Joe Moses the former
dean of the School of Engineering here
at MIT and now Provost Provost Moses
will take the time to recognize and
introduce this year's dr. Martin Luther
King jr. visiting professors Provost
Moses it is my privilege to introduce
the dr. Martin Luther King jr. visiting
professors this year are Chuck mentioned
the sparkplugs of this committee and a
couple years ago they came to visit the
various councils the engineering council
which I chaired at time the Science
Council they talked to the provost and
they had an idea of creating a visiting
professor program and contrary to MIT
this one we actually got implemented
very quickly and within a few months but
largely through the work of my
predecessor ma Crichton and this year we
have the second slight of visiting
professors and obviously this program is
intended to enhance recognize the
contribution of minority scholars
through a greater presence of these
minority scholars on the MIT campus and
this year we have six of visiting
professors and of whom four happened to
be here and can I can we'll ask him to
stand up in a minute or so last year we
had four and the fourth one happens to
be Wes Harris he stood up before but you
could stand up again Wes has rejoined
his original department
of aeronautics and Astronautics and
we're all very very pleased by that let
me introduce the sixth intern the first
one is mr. and esto Cortez who happens
to be the director of the Texas
industrial areas foundation and also
director of a more general foundation
the dust real areas foundation of the
southwest region this foundation creates
and supervises community-based
organizations in Texas Arizona New
Mexico Louisiana and Nebraska as well as
the United Kingdom his education he's
got a bachelor's degree in English and
economics for Texas A&M and did some
additional graduate studies and
economics at University of Texas and
Austin he is a professor of urban
studies and planning and one of the many
awards he's received was a MacArthur
Fellowship for his work in community
organizing which he received in 1984 so
although he's not here would you please
give a hand to mr. Cortes
[Applause]
next is Professor Richard Joseph who's
visiting us in the department political
science
he holds the bachelor's degree from
Dartmouth College a Bachelor philosophy
degree from New College Oxford and dr.
philosophy in 1973 from Muirfield
College in Oxford what I learned at
breakfast this morning is of course the
reason he was at Oxford as a Rhodes
Scholar he is currently the ASA Candler
professor of political science and Emory
University his teaching and research
interests include African politics and
political thought in politics and
literature professor Joseph please stand
up
professor Stephen Lee is visiting
Department of Mathematics teaches one of
my favorite courses 1806 he holds a
Bachelor of Science degree in Applied
Mathematics from Yale and dr. Philosophy
in computer science array from the
University of Illinois in
urbana-champaign his research interests
include differential and algebraic
equations and has the work he's done his
head's applications to groundwater
modeling and computational fluid
dynamics he has opposed at the Oak Ridge
National Laboratory in in addition to
which he's an adjunct assistant
professor at the University of Tennessee
at Knoxville in the department of
computer science professor Lee
[Applause]
dr. Oliver McGee the third is visiting
currently the department of civil
environmental engineering
he has a Bachelor Science degree from
Ohio State University and a master's
science PhD from the University of
Arizona
he's a associate professor at Georgia
Tech in the school of civil
environmental engineering which
presumably is in the college of
engineering and the ecology foundation
for the Advancement of teaching recently
named him the 1995 Georgia professor of
the Year congratulations and the current
research interests include computational
mechanics as well as into the his
interests are include also
interdisciplinary design optimization in
civil and in aerospace structural
systems miss McGee
[Applause]
dr. William white Quivers jr. is the
currently the chairman of the Department
of Physics at Wellesley College he is
gotten a Bachelor Science degree in
physics from Morehouse College and few
years later a PhD in physics at MIT
physics department and his research is
on laser spectroscopy he's at a long
association with with dr. Feld and he's
come here to work with him yet again so
they stand up
[Applause]
finally like to mention an introduced
professor Walter Rodriguez who is
currently visiting this department of
civil environmental engineering he is a
full professor hold of Louisbourg a
chair and design at tufts university
hispanic-american he's born in Puerto
Rico and he has provided leadership both
within his technical field and then the
recruitment promotion retention of
underrepresented minorities and women in
engineering education and practice he
brings to MIT a varied and valued set of
backgrounds and interests both in civil
engineering and in architecture and
currently is teaching an area is
construction management which is an area
of great interest in department of civil
environmental engineering would you
please give a hand to dr. reg redux
[Applause]
now last year we had four this year we
have six hopefully next year even more
see you then
[Applause]
thank you very much Provost Moses and I
like to invite president vest back up to
give some remarks in it and to introduce
our keynote speaker miss Elaine Jones
thank you I'm gonna tell you a secret
we've been hearing a lot about drum
majors today
Oliver McGee was the drum major the Ohio
State marching band and I don't know how
many of you know the significance of
that position but Becky and I used to
sit in the stands in Ann Arbor and watch
him in between the drumming of the
football team it's the fate of every
university president to face a heavy
schedule of speaking engagements
throughout the year some of these
engagements frankly are onerous many are
pleasant some are an honor most or a
duty but a few are inspirations and this
one always is such an event perhaps the
most inspiring of the year we celebrate
together the ideals and vision of dr.
Martin Luther King jr. for many reasons
for the challenges he called us to meet
for the courage he dared us to match for
the stirring eloquence that moved our
hearts and transformed our nation most
often however we say that we honor dr.
King's dream certainly his dream is as
powerful today as it was in 1964 when in
a single address he became the nation's
most compelling voice for racial
equality and social progress but Martin
Luther King jr. was above all as many
have said this morning a man of action
his dream is memorable and important
precisely because he did so much to make
it a reality if we wish to honor him as
Jim Gates said we must do the same the
dream is dream is not enough nor can we
build the Society of which he dreamed by
command or by decree rather we must work
proactively to build it through the
environments and the opportunities we
create for learning and working in the
years since dr. King's death many of our
nation's colleges and universities have
made a deliberate effort to infuse his
dream with some small measure of reality
over time one important pathway to his
goals which we have come to call
affirmative action has yielded
substantial results for example the US
Census data teller tells us that today
between excuse me that between 1980 and
1992 the aggregate percentage of
minorities in the US population has
remained fairly stable at just over 25%
in that time however the percentage of
minority undergraduates at u.s. colleges
and universities rose from 17.3% to
23.5% and that is progress by any
standard at the graduate education level
the rate of increase is comparable but
we do need to accelerate the pace in
order to reach a more acceptable
absolute number 1990 to just over 15% of
the graduate students in America were
minority students now that's a bit about
the national picture but how about here
at home at MIT well I have to say that
while we must continue worrying about
how to do better within this context of
national figures we do have some things
to be proud about and I want to share
them because it really is largely due to
many of the people sitting in this room
that we have come as far as we have come
just yesterday I received a report
regarding the enrollment of minority and
women students in engineering programs
throughout the US and it shows the
following over the last five years MIT
is in fact in the top ten in terms of
the number of engineering degrees
awarded at all levels to women to
African American students and to
Hispanic American students the others in
that list of top 10 are Georgia Tech
CCNY and seven historically black
colleges and universities an MIT ranks
number two in the country in terms of
the number of engineering doctoral
degrees awarded to African Americans and
we are number one
in terms of the number of engineering
doctoral degrees awarded both to
Hispanic American students and to women
we should be proud of these rankings but
the actual numbers show how far we still
have to go during this period we have
awarded a total of twelve hundred and
seven engineering Doctorate degrees we
have awarded a total of 170 of these two
women 19 to Hispanic Americans and 16 to
African Americans so just look at that
absolute number how small in fact they
are yet they still place us number one
and number two in the country with such
numbers despite their recent growth it
is no wonder that there are so few
minorities and women on the faculties of
our colleges and universities
when already still make up only 12% of
the American professorial and only eight
and a half percent of those who are full
professors the situation is far worse if
we look specifically at the fields of
science and engineering MIT is a case in
point clearly we have much more to do to
me at least these numbers have two
important implications the first is that
whatever its imperfections
affirmative action has improved access
and opportunity to women into minorities
in America the second is the deferment
of action as most of us know from
personal experience it's the hardest to
achieve the most gradual in its impact
at the highest levels of our society
real progress at these levels will occur
only with more time but much more
importantly with more effort is such an
effort necessary these numbers suggest
that exclusion and discrimination are
not merely historical artifacts but are
continuing realities they also suggest
that steady pressure must be maintained
until results are seen at the top to
quit now will simply mean long-term
stratification of opportunity a
permanent glass ceiling if you will why
then is affirmative action in higher
education under attack from so many
quarters this past July the Fifth
Circuit Court of Appeals ruled in
hopwood versus University of Texas that
quote any any consideration of race or
ethnicity by the Law School for the
purpose of achieving a diverse student
body is not a compelling interest quote
and therefore is not permitted at least
in Texas Mississippi and Louisiana the
repeal of affirmative action by the
University of California's Board of
Regents gained national attention during
the presidential campaign in Colorado
the Governing Board of the University
System has cut back on its affirmative
action programs most disturbingly
California voters approved a measure
which would forbid any state agency or
school from taking race or gender into
account for purposes of hiring or
admissions as you know implementation of
this measure is unhold pending the
outcome of several legal challenges I
believe that much of the support for
these assaults on affirm
of action derives from a fundamental
ignorance about the true position of
minorities in our nation that ignorance
was net was amply demonstrated in a
survey conducted in September of 1995
this study indicated that 41% of white
Americans believed that economically
African Americans were just as well or
better off than whites 44% of our white
population according to this survey
believed that African Americans are just
as well off or better off in terms of
educational achievement on the question
of economic well-being the reality is
that the mean household income for
African Americans despite its rise is
still only 65% that of white households
in terms of education enrollment and
employment for African Americans
especially in graduate schools as I
noted none faculties continues to lag
very substantially in addition to this
ignorance this lack of knowledge about
the present reality I believe that part
of the problem can be attributed to
ignorance about the population trends in
the United States while minorities
account for approximately a quarter of
our population today that figure will
rise to over 30% just by 2005 nearly 34
percent in 2015 and presumably will
continue to climb these trends suggest
to me if we just want to be pragmatic if
nothing else but the economic health of
our nation in the next century will rest
squarely on the productivity achievement
and skills of a workforce that is going
to be increasingly diverse in a
technology driven post-industrial
economy an economy in which education is
the single most important contributor to
success our nation simply cannot afford
to shortchange or ignore the educational
aspiration
of its historically disadvantaged
citizens and even as America's
population becomes increasingly diverse
the average age of Americans is also
increasing many of us feel this quite
personally so these days because the age
is creeping up we all hear a lot about
what the future of Social Security now
just think about this for a minute
white baby boomers are going to depend
for their retirement on taxes paid into
the system by a workforce that is
markedly more diverse than that that
exists today if that diverse workforce
has not received the best education we
can give it then we will face the
likelihood of severely constrained
Social Security benefits I know that
even in the face of these realities
there are many in America who still
argue that affirmative action is not a
necessary or valuable tool in building a
more equitable and productive society
even deprived of the argument the
deferment of action doesn't work or that
we don't need it anymore they will fall
back on the idea that it is wrong
because it violates the concept of
colorblindness
which dr. King himself characterized so
eloquently as the ability to judge
people not by the color of their skin
but by the content of their character
these are two responses to the challenge
of affirmative action one of these two
challenges has been made with particular
eloquence by one of the winners of
today's Martin Luther King Leadership
Award in July 1995 issue of the
scientist magazine Jim Gates wrote of
the value of genetic diversity in
promoting the survival performance vigor
and adaptability of biological systems
he suggested by analogy that the same
principle could and should be applied to
human societies this nation he argued
desperately needs to use all the means
at its disposal to achieve the highest
level of performance
and increasingly international
competition in science and technology
diversity he said in both nature and
other fields of human endeavor has shown
to lend itself to increased levels of
performance it is not prudent at least
to be open is it not prudent at least to
be open to this possibility in the
pursuit of excellence in scientific
engineering and technological
achievement jim's inspired defense of
the value of diversity may be extended
from science and technology to our
society as a whole we must pursue them
because they are right and just that is
why we need to ought to honor and to
emulate dr. King for although he was a
pragmatic activist he never let his
pragmatism dilute his idealism he knew
that only moral leadership can move
mountains and transform nations
I hope therefore that the students
faculty and staff of MIT will join me
during the year ahead and a renewed
effort to sustain our University's
commitment to diversity and opportunity
in all aspects of our scholarship and
their professional lives perhaps such a
commitment is in part just an expression
of pragmatic self-interest it also is an
expression of an abiding sense of
justice let us together pursue these
goals as dr. King did not because they
are good for us but simply because they
are good thank you
and now now it is a truly great
privilege and pleasure to introduce our
keynote speaker the position of Director
Council of the n-double-a-cp legal
defense and education fund was defined
by its first occupant Thurgood Marshall
because of Thurgood Marshall's
reputation and legacy it is a position
of immense influence and importance in
the continuing legal struggle to secure
equal rights for America's disadvantaged
citizens there can be no doubt however
that the current director counsel is up
to that task a 1968 honors graduate from
Howard University miss Jones spent two
years in Turkey with the Peace Corps
she returned to attend law school at the
University of Virginia
and became the first African American
woman to graduate from this illustrious
institution then she was given a choice
one of Wall Street's most prestigious
firms offered her the kind of job that
so many law school graduates dream of
but as she said in an interview this
last summer money wasn't the reason I
chose the law I went to law school to
use the law to serve the people and so
she joined the staff of the
n-double-a-cp Legal Defense and
education fund where with only two years
off for good behavior she's been working
ever since those two years by the way
she spent in the Carter administration's
Department of Transportation where she
served as special assistant to Secretary
William T Coleman jr. during her more
than 25 years with the Legal Defense and
education fund
she has argued many significant cases
beginning in 1972 with Furman versus
Georgia a landmark Supreme Court ruling
that put a stop to the death penalty in
37 states in addition to her courtroom
work
she's also compiled an impressive record
as a federal legislative advocate
and has worked closely with Congress in
shaping such critical civil rights
legislation as the Voting Rights
Amendment of 1982 the Fair Housing Act
of 1988 the Civil Rights Act of 1988 and
the Civil Rights Act of 1991 please join
me in welcoming to MIT and our community
with Lane R Jones
[Applause]
you have been a marvelous audience this
has been a wonderful program it is now
10 15 you're going to see what kind of
lawyer I am whether or not this is a
lady that knows how to get to the point
say well she has to stand sit down we'll
see all right where did I hear it was it
[Music]
Martin what who was it that said how
long old speaker how long not long my
captive audience not long
thank you thank you very much president
vest for that wonderful introduction
this has been a wonderful program
I am honored the opportunity to be with
you on this year 23rd celebration of the
life of dr. King that is impressive
23 years when I came here as an MIT 23
years not very very very good I also
just haven't listened to your speakers
and your honorees you know IDO and
Cedric you know I was willing to cede
some time you know if you had asked for
it you could have had a little of my
time I have a you know Jim Gates the
whole question of the sweden's of dreams
the idea of the nation mera Rodriguez
you could have had all of my time
all of my time and our professor Ellen
Harris and and dr. Festus it's been
wonderful this we take this occasion
just to stop and remind ourselves that
Martin was a man of action and so that's
what each one of us is called to do and
whatever role in life we find ourselves
it's to act and act on principles and
issues of importance now I look around
and I see the honorees and I think of
action and I I see Wesley Harris sitting
out there my classmate I was the first
african-american woman admitted to a
University of Virginia I know you need
needless to say Wes was the first of to
enter the engineering department at the
school at the University of Virginia and
I guess mr. Jefferson University looked
around in 1967 and said what have we
wrought what have we done were these two
I mean we were dashiki and afro and
Sanders
but we were there to graduate we were
telling one another we're not going to
be a statistic we're gonna graduate from
this University
while we're here we're gonna make the
difference that we can make but Virginia
is going to have to deal with us and I
mean we met we had some issues
I mean Charlottesville they often ask me
how Elaine did you cope and my response
was I had just comes from two years in
the Peace Corps in Turkey and it was
rather the Charlottesville was a breeze
next to Uncle so it's all relative it's
all relative but let me tell you and
looking at Martin's life and what we're
talking about the strength of love and
the issues of the underclass in my work
at the Legal Defense Fund you ask well
who are we who is LDF we're not in
double-a-c-p
the name is n-double-a-cp Legal Defense
Fund but we are separate if you come up
to me and ask me how is crazy and how is
Murli I would tell you I'm sure they're
fine you know but LDF is a separate
organization in a civil rights law firm
spun off from the n-double a-c-p in 1940
Thurgood Marshall was our first director
counsel followed by Jack Greenberg in
1961 Julia Seamus in 1984 and I became
director counsel in 1993 we have had
more cases in the High Court than any
other organization with the extinction
of the Solicitor General's Office of the
Department of Justice over 500 cases we
know how to litigate that we know how to
do but as director counsel South Bend
director counsel I have been trying to
use our legal skills in other capacities
as well to try to negotiate and mediate
some of these disputes to try to get in
their community and recognize some of
the problems and use our legal
skills short of having to file a
complaint next we have to file it we're
fine but that is a whole area in terms
of pushing and promoting these issues
that ldf has been able to make a
difference in over the past few years
and I just want to share a few of those
with you one of the first issues we
should think about is we are often
divided on subjects of the civil rights
laws we are there trying to pick men
against women women against men that
disabled against the age and and what is
missing is a full understanding that
these issues are interrelated when you
think of the n-double a-c-p legal sense
fun what did our cases are not
determined by the race of the plaintiffs
it is the issue that is presented to
give you an example you have to be
strategic as martin was when you're
thinking about the high court and what
we're going to do and how we're going to
go about bringing these cases a year ago
a case came to me white female from
tennessee age discrimination case 62
years old dismissed
brought the lawsuit in her deposition
which is her sworn testimony it was
discovered that she had taken some
documents home so the that was a
dismissable offense and so the
corporation argued well even if we did
dismiss her on the basis of age although
we don't admit that even if we did that
was negated by the fact that she had
taken these documents home and that was
something called the after-acquired
Evidence Rule you know they make this
complicated but it's not they asked the
quite evidence ruining it went up to the
court of appeals and through the
district court and they ruled against
her
her lawyer came to the legal defense
fund in double acp legal defense fund
that asks us to take that case to the
High Court this past year
I looked at it and I wondered about what
sir good would do outside of yes we
would take that case for several reasons
one
it's a age case and it doesn't hurt the
Supreme Court sometimes has difficulty
looking at race claims or understanding
of gender claim but in each I thought
they would all understand not only that
you you look at the context is coming
from Tennessee and it doesn't hurt that
it's not an african-american plaintiff
that it is a white female because there
are two women on the court will seem to
understand those issues so that's why I
thought it best to bring an issue in the
gender context we won that case non-0 is
a member of the court because it's the
point that martin has made about the
interrelationship of our issues how we
all sing together we swim together or we
sing his quote is the black community
cannot win this victory alone but
intelligent men and women of good will
everywhere might see this as their task
and contribute to its support he says if
we look honestly for coalition we will
find it if we choose polarization it
will not acquire much effort but we have
got we have got opportunities here when
we understand how our issues issues that
affect women issue that affect disabling
as a lawyer these statues are all
interrelated this whole notion of an
after quiet Evidence Rule if it had
seeped into the law it would have
negated a lot of cases that have come
under different provisions age disabled
and rapes now
as we look at this notion of an activist
society we have to be committed to
something other than self we have to
have a sense of community and a shared
sense of joy and pain we have to be
involved in activities that affect the
interests of the larger community your
president in a report of the president
1995-96 writes today we have evolved
into a truly paradoxical situation we
have by a huge margin the greatest and
most effective system of higher
education in the world in terms of
quality accessibility and creation of
new knowledge he goes on to say at the
same time we have a system of primary
and secondary education that is a
national shame one that is a surefire
determinant of national decline if it is
not corrected
he is right LDF agrees and we have been
fighting these issues of school
desegregation for 40 years and what the
public does not understand is that when
they come to us and say well Elain why
don't you look more at issues involving
quality of education rather than a
desegregated education but see in Brown
versus Board of Education integrated
education was an independent ground it
was an important in the Pendergraft and
it is still of great value that we have
a desegregated environment for our
children but putting that aside where is
it in the law that there is a federal
right to equal access to public
education equal as access to quality
public education it does not exist as a
matter of federal law it is not in our
Constitution there is no constitutional
amendment or provision which provides
is that right so if you're going to look
at the issues of quality in schools you
have to do it through the 14th amendment
through equal protection analysis so if
I go into court I have no jurisdictional
basis as a matter of federal law to go
into court and argue for equality of
opportunity in inner-city schools it's a
shame but it's the way it is so what do
we have to do we have to be creative
LDS looked at all of the state
constitutions a few years ago and we
were looking for a state constitutional
provision which gave us the strong
language we needed to challenge the
quality of schools in a particular inner
city then half the city in mind had to
find the constitutional provision first
looked at the ones from all of the
states and what did we find as a service
for one in Connecticut doctors in 1968
which provided for equal educational
opportunity and access for all students
through education public quality
education so then we go to Connecticut
and in Connecticut we see the deplorable
situation in the Hartford Public Schools
and we say well this will be the test
case in Hertford we see all of the
inner-city students regardless of race
regardless of race Latino white black
makes no difference we represented all
of the students with in the Hartford
Public Schools and we solved in 1990 on
behalf of 17 african-american Latino and
white public school children and a
complaint against the State Board of
Education the governor and other
officials and we alleged that the
Hartford metropolitan schools were
segregated on the basis of race ethnic
background and
see economic status and because the
Hartford schools are educationally
deficient when compared to the suburban
schools we alleged that the defendants
failed to provide plaintiffs an equal
opportunity to a free public education
as required by the Connecticut
Constitution then we went on to say that
the Sharps segregation of the students
on the basis of race which was palpable
in Hartford
by itself violated the Constitution
we tried that case before the state
court in 1990 and all the way through
1992 the trial court issued an opinion
on a vemma 13 1994 ruling against us we
then had developed quite a record so we
went to the Connecticut Supreme Court
and a Connecticut Supreme Court heard
that case in September of 1995 or an
expedited appeal and this past July 9
released a decision in which they ruled
for us they ruled that the combination
of racial segregation created
substantially unequal education
opportunity and requires the state to
take further remedial measures in other
words it was the first time we had
gotten a state Supreme Court based on
its its own Constitution to determine
that the quality of education is being
awarded to those inner-city schools was
constitutionally deficient now we're in
the remedial phase what is the remedy
working with the governor working with
the legislature trying to decide what it
is that we do in terms of allocation of
resources among those districts all
kinds of resources so those kids will be
able to compete if we can work this out
in Hartford
and we can take this this this win which
is a very important victory and
transport it to other jurisdictions but
you have been reading about it maybe in
the New York Times but that is a case
that came about because of some creative
lawyering and now the community has
decided to support the litigation your
president met you're Hopwood you cannot
litigate these cases if you are viewing
the case as a means to win public often
somewhere in the future
you can't litigate my press conference
now if you really want to represent the
interest a fault and Hopwood is the
example of litigation by press
conference first you have a plan that
that the University of Texas had been
told by self including us that it was
doubtful whether that plan could pass
constitutional muster told him in
1990-91
to make some changes in the planet when
the plan was challenged and he lost the
case in the district court when I left
to the court of appeals when it got to
the court of appeals law stood before
the three judges at that point they
wanted to go to the Supreme Court of the
United States why would one want to take
an affirmative action case in higher
education last term to this Court
if one had an alternative when a
three-judge Court rules against you that
is the entire Court of seventeen judges
who was prepared to hear the case the
motion was never fired to ask the entire
court to indicate instead the lawyers
were so busy trying to get their day in
a Supreme Court with the press and PR
that they overlooked the court that they
were in intentionally overlooked the
court they were
because we asked him to find was having
filed in the Supreme Court the remaining
judges seven of them that had not been
on the original panel in the court of
appeals wrote an opinion they no longer
had jurisdiction they wrote an opinion
and they said where is the case we
disagreed with the opinion that our
brothers have written where is the case
we want an opportunity to speak to these
issues no longer had jurisdiction could
never speak the Supreme Court then
decided not to hear the case and very
fortunately didn't hear it very
fortunate didn't hear the case on these
facts Supreme Court didn't hear it so
what is left standing
what is left standing is the original
decision written by the three judges
whereas if the petition for rehearing
had been found the conclusion of the
court may have been the same but the
opinion would have been different you
would not have a lower court trying to
overrule baki
so I just say that there are special
circumstances due to these cases High
Court as president vest has told you is
Mississippi Texas and Louisiana and even
with hot water there was an agreement of
all of the parties that the plan that
Texas has adopted was unconstitutional
and the reason the Supreme Court didn't
take the case is because the court has
said there's no issue here in
controversy there may be another from
the Vashon case in the Supreme Court
within the next couple of years right
now barking continues to be good long
the last time I looked at lower court
cannot overrule a Supreme Court decision
the last time I checked that out
couldn't be done now the court has
spoken at a Duran and some of the
feminization cases but even in those
cases the court has not declared those
programs unconstitutional it has set
them back to the lower court for review
one final point about how a week
sometimes can get misguided and where we
need to go and how we need to get there
and then I'm going to sit down Jim is
from the University of Milan the
relationship between Thurgood Marshall
and Martin Luther King is an interesting
one Thurgood Marshall as head of the
legal defense fire and Martin Luther
King was engaged in his direct action
and it is reported the third good start
that Martin was endangering the lives of
folks and said well Martin you know
maybe you you don't want to have so much
mass direct action and Martin said no it
takes two it takes you Thurgood doing
what you are doing and it takes me
having this mass action being out in the
community in the street and forcing
people to take notice of these issues
and he said I'm gonna do what I must do
and if you sir good are the lawyer that
I think you are then you come down to
get me out of jail and that is what ever
you have spent vi is doing now so good
Thurgood Marshall I first directed
counsel when he graduated from the
Howard University School of Law in 1933
first in his class the first thing that
he did his first order of business was
to sue the university around because
third would had applied to the
University morale afford mission and
Marilyn had a rule no blacks and he
refused to admit him on the basis of
race so when he graduated he had that
unfinished business to take care of so
he Charlie Houston filed the lawsuit
against Marla I admit the first black to
the law school merit versus the
university mine and they won it and so
that was the whole series of cases than
the 30s and 40s the cases that were the
precursors to brown but the point is mom
Marilyn had that long history of
discrimination over palpable clear
discrimination against African Americans
Oh from 36 all the way through in 1970
Merlin was one of the 11 states as part
of the Adams litigation assist involves
17 southern states looking at the high
education systems Marilyn happens in
such violation of this elementary
principle that the Office of Civil
Rights told Maya look you need to do
something set up a scholarship program
you know you need to do something to let
ask that Americans know that they're
welcome in this institution rather than
recognizing that it needed to do
business differently set up the Benjamin
Banneker Scholarship Program to admit
high achieving
inner-city Aspen American students and
to give them a scholarship the program
worked beautifully throughout the late
seventies worked almost too well I guess
because it did begin to change the
character and culture at Maryland that
program was challenged LDF came in with
the Attorney General's Office and spent
thousands of dollars to sitting the
program had a Reagan judge a six-week
trial a 56 page opinion in which the
judge upheld the program then it went
upstairs to the Court of Appeals by the
language means everything we argued the
case before the court of appeals the
judges were turned to the side side we
weren't even looking at us as we were
making their hard was I hope that they
read the papers and we want we lost it
in no time flat it took them a couple of
weeks to write an opinion but here's
what they had done they struck down the
benjamin banneker scholarship program
which did begin to make the difference
at mine a program to bring in inner-city
high achieving african-american students
we pay twenty thousand dollars a year
for an inmate in general population
eating three meals a day looking at
television we spend seventy five
thousand dollars a year for inmate and
solitary confinement and we cannot spend
five thousand dollars a year
for inner-city high achievement
african-american student to get higher
education at the same time that the
circuit strikes down their program these
other programs are in place and iPhone
scholarship program for descendants of
early Dutch settlers scholarship
programs for American citizens of
Canadian descent scholarship programs
for students of Greek descent familiar
income families scholarships for
students born in Hong Kong scholarships
for students from Taiwan scholarships
for females who do not use tobacco
scholarships scholarships for students
of Chinese or Japanese descent
scholarships for deserving students of
Italian descent from upstate New York I
mean it goes on and on so how warped we
become when we look at these questions
of race especially in a remedial context
I want to say that there are lots of
structural issues of discrimination out
here that we are coping with we just we
just had a major case in Los Angeles you
go to LA and you can't get a bus the
math the transportation system there is
a multi-billion dollar transportation
system they had a three hundred and
forty eight million dollar surplus and
they were building six rail out the back
Pasadena where folks in the inner city
can't give a bus to go to work to go to
day care to go to the drugstore to go to
the supermarket
no buses the people are subsidized
coming in from the suburbs two cars in
the garage getting a subsidy from their
employer to take mass transit folk in
the city nothing LDF came in to the
public hearings pleading no lawsuits
filed part of the director councils new
obligation or her lawyers go to the
public hearing try to reason with takes
money I mean I my my Supreme Court law
clerks come to me at certified 140
thousand dollars that's that's it that's
what we paid but these are people who in
the tradition of Martin understand
the purpose of the law is in the first
instance is to bring some justice to the
people it's to make a difference in the
lives of people and I want to thank you
for the invitation to be with you today
and I I just it's very very important as
we look about the country and and see
the issues that are going on to think
about what you'll speaker last year said
to you Julie Australis Julius asked you
last year who is my predecessor as
director counsel why are we gather here
today to commemorate dr. King are we
gathered to praise and endorse his
teachings he says do we seriously
believe that America were ever eliminate
considerations of race are we simply
commemorating an imagined memory showing
our faces to prove that we are not
racist are we giving lip service with
little or no commitment to the genes of
dr. King well charity begins at home and
I'm here for the next day and you know
there are some issues here with the
school system in Boston there are some
Zarate's I mean I have never seen a more
rigidly stratified system where students
are trapped in elementary school the
tests they're giving in eighth grade
largely determines where they're going
to go I mean at first is within the
classroom and then a separate classroom
within a separate school now maybe it
exists elsewhere in the country and I'm
looking for it I assure you I'm looking
for it
but I haven't seen it kind of thing
needs to be looked at I mean and it
needs to be handled by the soap at home
who can see what impact this is having
on the aspirations hopes and development
of kids are you really measuring a
child's aptitude at age eight so as to
lock that kid in to a special child for
the next ten years are you doing
and so it's a very very real issue and I
invite you to to look at it and work on
it and investigate it and study it if
you need a little help let me know I
want to end with this start and that is
you know I have the nerve to paraphrase
Longfellow Longfellow but it's what
Martin life was about and what he taught
us lives of great men and women all
remind us we can make our lives sublime
and departing leave behind us footprints
Martin left footprints on the sands of
time footprints that perhaps another
stealing or life Salomon a forlorn or
shipwrecked brother or sister see it
shall take harder game let us then be up
and doing action doing with a heart for
any fate still achieving still pursuing
learn to labor into it I thank you all
very very much
[Applause]
on behalf of the entire MIT community
mrs. Jones thank you very much
[Applause]
we continue our program with some
announcements relevant to our
celebration tomorrow evening in all day
Saturday we will be sponsoring a
day-long youth conference entitled
building bridges for youth into the
future we're expecting over 300 youth
from both Cambridge and Boston as well
I'd like to announce that the Martin
Luther King committee presents journey
into a dream a musical tribute to dr.
Martin Luther King jr. with semenya
McCord and associates this musical
presentation will be held on Saturday
February 8th at 8 p.m. in Kresge
Auditorium these both of these events
are free and open to the public as well
we'd like to thank our awardees families
dr. gazes wife Diana an MIT alum Emmys
Mario Rodriguez parents church and
family for attending thank you and as a
final announcement as you exit both
doors a book reflections of the dream
1975 to 1994 will be on sale the book
documents 20 years of celebrating life
of dr. Martin Luther King jr. at MIT and
it's edited by dr. clarence williams at
this time ladies and gentlemen near
program are the wards words to the black
national anthem lift every voice and
sing by mr. James Weldon Johnson at this
time everyone please rise join hands and
follow along as soloists miss Juanita
Jackson and pianist George W Russell jr.
lead us in singing
[Music]
with
rejoicing
[Music]
me
louder
[Music]
Oh
see
hello there faith that the dog has has
time
[Music]
the hope that the present
they say no
[Music]
ooh
and a smart choice
to be
to
is my
stoning the wrong
[Music]
there
my day
[Music]
and
yet with the stand
[Music]
not away
come to the play
[Applause]
which I
[Music]
[Applause]
overweight is that
[Music]
try Dana
Oh
we stand
[Music]
why
we
is God
my son
[Music]
Hasbro
yes bye
[Music]
kay
[Applause]
the
[Music]
a stray from the places God
star
drunk with the wine
[Music]
shadow beanie
for
[Applause]
[Music]
- -
- to our name
[Music]
lift every voice insane
let every voice and sing
[Music]
maybe seated I was very careful not to
let the microphone pick up my voice I'd
like to call Reverend Constance F Harvey
to return to the stage she'll offer the
benediction to close this morning's
program
Reverend parva thank you oh what a
beautiful morning when the stars came
out to shine it's that kind of day let
us pray
gracious Lord as we here have been
blessed by coming together in this
common celebration may we go forth not
only celebrating but leading the journey
into a world culture where there is no
race racism no prejudice we're all
really how can achieve what they are
endowed with our inaudible rights that
all of us may become instruments of
justice of truth of reconciliation and
peace this we pray as we celebrate this
a day our brother Martin and all his
friends amen
Thank You Reverend Parveen ladies and
gentlemen this marks the end of our
program hope everyone has enjoyed
themselves as much as I have thank you
all for coming and I hope to see you
next year
this concludes the 23rd annual dr.
Martin Luther King breakfast thank you
and good day
[Applause]